pour que nos amis téléspectateurs
puissent se faire une idée très précise
sur le mental le psychisme des mafieux
berne
on va faire une petite interview ici et
on ne bouge pas jingle voulez vous
relaxer un petit peu avant de commencer
souvent dario n'oublie pas ses tubes et
un chant traditionnel mais j'ai vu bong
la télévision cette semaine dire que le
tibet est une province de la chine
ça dure ça fait pourtant les jo league
anglais alors est ce que vous êtes
parano non pas vraiment est ce que vous
êtes schizo temps en temps avec mon
travail avec votre travail je vous êtes
maso tant de temps à z
est ce que vous êtes sadou est pas trop
non je vous ai de sado maso bon patron
géronto géronto c'est quand on aime les
personnes plus âgées
le personnage vraiment mais c'est pas
vraiment être un wheeling ouais c'est
pas votre truc non est ce que vous êtes
porno ça veut dire qu'on regarde et que
cette temps ce temps je crois mais pour
nous c'est bien
joie la cuisine dans le fond là bas qui
se dit mais qu'est ce que je fous là
camarades bien est-ce que vous êtes
fétiche au nom exhibo oui à adam aux
normes et mon travail c'est vraiment mal
je commets sélection est ce que vous
êtes pédo non bien sûr non avait il fait
les deux ans les jeunes mamans c'est un
peu ce que vous êtes aux ânes on pense
quoi exactement j'ai bien non merci
beaucoup et marin
et maintenant